so good evening everyone I am vedika and
I've been a research fellow for with
omic logic from the last September month
of September and I got introduced to
this uh platform as we had to do a minor
project in college and we were just
looking for internships most of the
tutorials were closed because of the
Corona virus so my juniors introduced me
to this tutorial and I thought yeah it
would be a great opportunity to learn
bioinformatics as you know it's the need
of the hour and most of the drug
designing or looking at the genius
are you able to hear me
yes yes
okay so this is how I got started that
um we had to do this internship and I
mean my minor project so I came here and
I have so I'll talk a little bit about
me I have a basic degree in
biotechnology I've also done my masters
in biotechnology and can we have the
next slide please
foreign
microbiota and its relationship with
brain disease diseases in the
development of the brain then I I also
got interested in transfer cancer
transcriptomics when I came here and
biology these are my basic three
interests so interestingly before I came
here I just knew enough bioinformatics
for me to write my midterm exams and
assignments and I can navigate ncbi that
was the kind of person I was and
sometimes I also had to work harder on
other assignments and give them to my
class fellows so they would give me
their bioinformatics assignments and
they would help me with the notes this
is how it was I get started I come here
it's all about bioinformatics I was
excited I'm going to learn something
that's going to teach me about skills
that we can currently use in every field
so and this is how I started and then I
ended up working on two projects can we
have the next slide
before that I would like to tell you
that when I got started with my research
Fellowship we did a couple of
um projects that actually helped me
understand what the basics of
bioinformatics is all about and we did
the bytes and molecule scores where I
also learned about things like
metagenomics and I learned about a
little bit about astrobiology and then
the basic tools that we use in
bioinformatics the databases and a
little bit about statistics then we came
to the transcriptomics course where I
basically got introduced to Next
Generation sequencing and how the
biological data that is generated from
various experiments or if it's even
found in silico we are able to map the
gene expressions and we are able to
learn how the gene sequencing is done
and the with the help of that data we
can do some statistical analysis we can
look at the pathways that are involved
in diseases we can look at the molecular
mechanisms and we are able to look at
the basics of diseases and also with the
Curative intent and look at some
biomarkers so obviously we've learned
all these Concepts we've learned the
statistics you've learned the formulas
now you also need to put it in the form
of a bioinformatics project so I also
did a course where actually I was taught
how to write reports from start to
finish what the structure is supposed to
be like how you're supposed to ask your
questions because I think that the
question is the Crux of your project if
you have a good research question and
it's strong enough for you to
differentiate your data between the
disease State and the non-disease state
or you are able to look at gene
expression which is involves genes that
are highly regulated or down regulated
so we are able to look at the elements
that form the molecular basis of
diseases and we can differentiate them
this was the courses that I did the next
slide please
so my first project was about the
transcriptomics analysis of clinical
data in kobit 19. the goal of this
project was as we know that
um last year the pandemic was in full
spring and we had several waves so we
looked at patients that were mildly
moderately and severely infected in
various days which was like the first
day and after a week the patients were
infected with the virus and we wanted to
correlate the severity of the disease
with the viral load that they were
infected with and what we did was that
we ended up collecting some data from uh
patients which we were able to find on
the jio website as a as in database and
then we performed certain tests on it
and statistical exams and then we ended
up doing the PCA so the PCA it's
basically a dimensionality reduction
it's a tool I know it sounds like a big
word right now for people who are like
me and just got are getting introduced
to bioinformatics but at multiple genes
in multiple conditions we are basically
able to look at them in a unified way
that what direction of the disease are
they taking us to and then we also
looked at the expression of genes of
different kinds and we were able to see
that genes are severely differentially
expressed in the mild and Progressive
stage so it's also because of how your
immune system responds to the disease
and if noted on some Pathways also like
the Jack start pathway and the cytokine
cytokine the separate interactions which
are able to tell the cause of your
disease that if you will be infected
mildly or moderately or it will give you
a severe disease also what was very
interesting to look at
was that
um when we looked at the viral load we
found no differences between people who
were mildly infected and moderately
infected and severely infected we did
find differences in their gene
expression like you can see I've drawn
the plots also and we have a bunch of
points that are segregated on the plots
towards it's right and the left which
shows us that there are differences in
gene expression but it doesn't mean that
if you have a highly infected uh viral
load and you're just having mild disease
you will not be able to you know spread
the disease to others so it's also
important for mildly or healthy people
to stay indoors and prevent the spread
of the disease can we have the next
slide
then I did another project over here
which was a part of my Master's
dissertation and since I was interested
in cancer biology but I think this feel
like since so many people have been
working on it it's become a bit
repetitive so just to make it more
interesting or make it more fun my
instructor Dr raghavi suggested that I
could look at the tumor microenvironment
as what the tumor microenvironment does
is it it's basically a niche of cells of
growth factors of signaling elements
that our leukemia cells are surrounded
with and we should be able to look at
that is the tumor micro environment also
a cause of being able to
generate this disease state or it's able
to turn the space leukemia the the kind
of leukemia that I worked on it being
it's basically about B cells so is it
able to drive the proliferation of the B
cells in such a direction that it
becomes disease and what how it exists
in certain kinds of tissues like the
peripheral blood and the lymph node as
we know that the lymph node is
responsible for the growth and for the
proliferation of these Mason cells into
the adult of full grown cells which will
then go on and provide immune responses
again we did some PCA we did some
statistical analysis like the taste test
so we could differentiate between
different groups of the disease then we
also looked at the differential gene
expression as you can see over here in a
figure that the genes on the right side
that are outside of the cutoff and are
colored they were highly upregulated and
they were causing certain changes in the
cells such as it could be that this is
immune function it could be uh you know
down regulated or within the cell cycle
certain checkpoints if they are released
and the cells are oh and the genes are
overactive it would not be able to cross
the checkpoints in the correct pathway
or the growth of the cells would not
stop at the required points that will
lead to an indefinite growth uh growth
and proliferation of the cells also we
learned that the tumor micro environment
is able to very significantly affect the
progression and occurrence of this
disease as they can be uh as a tumor
microenvironment can make the Dell uh
can make the cells highly refractive to
the kind of disease uh that you're in
and the drugs that are used for it and
it also increases the inflammation that
the cells are um increased to and it's
also responsible for DNA damage in the
sense
so this is a brief overview and I'll be
showing you the projection how to write
these reports and how to go about the
courses in detail can we have the next
slide please
um so like I said I have a degree in
biotechnology but sometimes you know
with the with such degree you're also
interested in looking at other fields so
I am currently working as a market
research training in global uh training
and global data PLC where I would say
that my work is more towards the
business side where we look at the
shares and revenues of companies but we
are able to also map it to the concepts
of biotechnology that we use in making
the medical devices that have just
published but uh it would definitely my
dream job would be to again go back to
research and look at how these molecular
mechanisms are causing diseases and what
differentially expressed genes are there
how do we sequence them and little bit
to be able to touch upon the Curative
approaches I think this would be the
most interesting thing so I'm going to
be working towards that and coming to
the uh the work that I done I had
written a poster about it but if I'm
able to gather more data sets which can
establish a stronger link between the
tumor micro environment and the
occurrence of the disease or in terms of
the occurrence of the covert disease and
then we draw more diagrams we make it
more systematic we perform more
statistical analysis on it then I can
turn it towards a paper publishing
so now heading to
um the portal I'll be showing you my
portal and then you can take a look at
the courses you can take a look at the
kind of projects that we've done and how
do we submitted
so we have shared the link to verica's
profile in the chat so that the
participants can go through her profile
along this way
so let me do later for you
I'm going to share my screen with you so
you can take a look
so
would you like to start explaining
vedika
uh yeah we can do that can you go to the
courses section yes we have the courses
section right now
so as you can see in on your omex logic
profile you will have a section where
you're supposed to talk about your
research interests you can give a little
bio about yourself and then you get
started with the basic courses like I
just said I was also a beginner in
advance and I mean I barely knew
anything about practical bioinformatics
except for what I had to do in class to
get my kids never knew it would look so
fascinating to me and it would just be
very interesting so you can start let's
start off with your bytes and molecules
course and then you can also get an
introduction to bioinformatics the
introductory course basically tells you
what bioinformatics is all about and how
you can use Big Data like we know that
you know when we work with such uh on
even in research projects or at a small
level you are required to work with
thousands of genes and you cannot just
you know quantify them at once or you
cannot just look at the differences
between them at once so big data it's
very important to learn those techniques
and learn how we can you know do the how
we can use it in bioinformatics then in
the bytes and molecules course you will
also get an overview to the kind of
fields that you're able to use
bioinformatics in and you will get to
learn how to use ncbi you will get to
learn how to
um visualize genes and how um you know
the process of transcription translation
the biological part of it works
uh you can do that and then you'll also
learn a little bit about proteins and
interestingly I learned that it's also
important to look at the transcriptome
and not just a DNA sequence over here
can you please get to the
transcriptomics course please open it so
we can talk alongside thank you
so like we say that the DNA expression
it is a bit static since you know this
uh the the genetic expression of cells
you are born with it but it's the
transcripts that undergo more
modifications and they will ultimately
lead to the production of the protein
products that are responsible for you
know the occurrence of diseases
or the differences in Pathways or The
Botch growth signaling factors Etc
so you will begin with learning NGS and
NGS is also very in technique these days
you will learn how to do the RNA
sequencing you will learn how to prepare
your data for Downstream analysis you
will learn statistics and I think the
most interesting course is to begin with
for me when I learned about RN is rnac
techniques where we were able to look at
Raw reads and we were able to figure
them out how we map them how we
determine what genes they are
then coming to the differential gene
expression and Gene enrichment which is
something that we also do very often in
our projects and then you can also when
you move on you can go to the machine
learning systems and then you will learn
how to do supervised in unsupervised
machine learning and for those of you
into coding you can learn python you can
learn R these are the languages that
basically we use for coding since I
don't have so much of a coding
background so
my instructor he helped me with the
coding part sometimes we need to
segregate the data sometimes we need to
look at plenty of data so I got help
with that
and uh
you know you can also look at other
kinds of courses like they also have
some demo project courses like the liver
cancer one the one on Covert since last
year covet was in full swing so you know
everybody wants to learn that and I
think this also ignited our
um interest in virology again otherwise
mostly people are concentrating towards
neuroscience and cancer biology
so that is that you can take a look at
the courses of your interest and you
will also learn what databases what
tools to use and Within These courses
what is interesting is that you'll also
have some practice exercises so it's
just not reading up stuff on your own in
theory you'll have these practice
exercises that you can work on yourself
and then you can come back to your
doubts I also felt like to begin with
when I was beginning with these courses
I think it got a bit difficult for me to
understand what these signatures are and
how you use these transcriptomic
strategies and how the G how do you look
at Gene maps and when you have to
combine a lot of approaches it does get
a bit tricky to learn with so your
instructors will help you with that
they'll give you one-on-one classes and
um and the practice exercises yeah like
I said they really help
now coming to the core the projects that
I worked on
here's another resource that you can
look at just for the Coronavirus and
you'll also learn about a little bit of
the epidemiology you will learn about
how we can back trace it to the
organisms like
we all know the story of Wuhan and how
the coronavirus spread from there and
it's also very related to
bats and pangolins this family of the
virus that's infecting people in that
cause the epidemic so like so we just
get to the the covid-19 project
I'll take you through it
so while you write your projects you
have uh it's it's a set of steps that we
have to follow and I think it's
something that we do everywhere even
when we write a report or you want to do
a research paper you will get start off
with collecting your data set then
working on it
um through your materials and Method
section and then you should be able to
derive some
uh con some significant results and you
will be able to look at the data that
way so then you write an abstract about
what you do in the project then you
write give an introduction to the
theoretical part like you could talk
about what the coronavirus is all about
what are the stages of the disease and
how do people get infected then you will
tell them the methods that you did like
I just talked about the statistical
analysis and the principle uh the PCA
and stuff like that then you can discuss
what did you learn from the project you
can also talk about your results before
that you obviously you'll be doing the
results first and then the discussion
what is what is it that you can draw and
what can you attribute the diseases to
and it's not only limited to diseases if
you're interested in the
agriculture side or if you're interested
in the microbial side you can also do
projects like that then you'll conclude
your project you'll give your references
and then you'll give an acknowledgment
so this is a format this is like a
standard format that you should keep in
mind when you are writing a project so
basically when I did the covet project
um what we did was that was an
introduction we were able to look at uh
the Genome of the covet uh the covet
virus a little bit we got an
introduction to it that it has about uh
you can say it shares about 80 to 90
percent of its uh sequence with bat and
Pangolin virus and then uh
the the gene uh or I would rather call
it the DNA of the virus
um so they are uh the genetic material
or the RNA of the virus it ports for
various
um segments of the virus like the uh
orfs and then the envelope and the
membrane and the spike and then the
capsid protein code like we all read
about in our biology classes and
sometimes they also have some accessory
proteins that help the virus penetrate
better into the cells and cause the
disease so this is some uh basic
introduction to covet and then what this
pipe protein of the cover does it that
it binds to Ace receptors which are also
some receptors that are like highly
concentrated in our heart and lungs and
many uh drugs are also made against
these receptors then the covet virus
from your nasal tract it goes into your
lungs and then whatever the disease
severity has to occur it occurs so like
we collected this data
uh for this uh for this project and we
collected about 180 samples from 98
people which was segregated into the
base day of the disease they were
diagnosed and then a week later or five
days later where you can look at the
profession then we did the PCA for it
where we kept the threshold that if the
gene expression
um uh it occurs Beyond a certain level
then only we will consider it
significant uh which was done in the
quantile normalization step where
basically you will transform the genes
into a bunch which can be compared with
each other because you don't want any
kind of background noise or genes that
are not significant in a very mildly
expressed that won't change the course
of the disease uh to affect your results
then you do some differential gene
expression about it you will select
thousands of genes you will cut them
down to the genes that it's that cause
the disease and then you can help with
the help of various diagrams and charts
and bar plots you can look at the
results so we found out that like I've
written here that the covert disease it
gives you a very hyperinflammatory State
and there are various Pathways and
uh genes that you know will also affect
the ability of the immune responses that
are who that the host will do to the
viral proteins in the form of cytokines
Etc
so this was a little technical sci-fi
facts of the project
and then I'll also walk you through the
other project which I had done as part
of my
final final years Master's dissertation
I came back here again because like it
was covered and what would you think of
doing so you know the uh this like all
these institutions are foreclosed but
I'm so glad I did it it was there it was
a very interesting project to work on
and the good thing about it is it's all
of it is so interactive that you know
you're able to visualize it with your
eyes you're able to dive into genes and
you're able to look at the results
instead of just sitting in class and
just reading theoretically about things
which I know can get a bit dry and
uninteresting to work on
so to begin with for a project you will
also get some data sets uh which you
will like I said you can obtain it from
the jio website or any other database
model related to your disease and then
you can you'll get the counts of the
kind of genes and the gene expression
that occurs in a disease uh you can take
the raw data and then you can work on it
you can perform your statistical tests
you can annotate it to the various Gene
IDs you can look at the pathways that
are involved in the disease
so we'll just get to the introduction in
the method section I can just talk about
so basically again get an idea about
what the projects are all about
so again chronic lymphocytic leukemia it
is a disease that affects uh the B cells
where the immature B cells they are they
undergo such high levels of
proliferation that uh the count crosses
a certain value which is obviously
medically kept as a cut off and it can
cause that's why it can cause various
symptoms and the stages of the disease
so what we did was that we again we
collected some data from jio uh this
time like I said that you know not only
the disease you can also look at the
various types of tissues that are
involved in a disease like we did
peripheral blood and lymph node
and uh we also looked at other
conditions of the kind of cells in the
markers that they showed we chose cd19
because it's highly uh uh I would say
like a statutory when it comes to this
disease so it helps us differentiate
between healthy and the disease cells
then we again did the PCA we did some uh
differential genix uh special and a lot
of these uh steps were done on the T
bioinforce service platform which is uh
here you can look at the pipelines you
put the data in and you get the results
out with the certain conditions that you
expose your data to
then we had to also statistically
determine that if the gene that
differentially expressed do they even
make any sense for them uh to to be this
way or not so we did that we use certain
formulas and tests and then again we did
the differential gene expression and
with the help of Gene autology we were
able to concentrate uh the genes that
affect the molecular and biological
functions of the disease so you can use
various online tools you can also code
and look at the uh the kind of diseases
and the genes you're looking at so that
is one thing if we get to the results of
the project you can just see that it
looks very interactive when you do it in
the form of charts and plots and it also
gives you a lot of clarity so like you
can see that the various subgroups of
the disease like lymph node or blood or
the disease or the cells that were
healthy enough
and the unhealthy cells that also had
more purpose we determined them uh their
propensity to cause a disease in the
terms of certain percentages and you see
that how they differentiated on the
charts also you can like I just talked
about in our previous project also that
the upregulated and non-jaculated genes
we can see not only how much they change
and how they change and what these
mutations are able to cause
now coming to the discussion and
conclusion of the project so we did
learn
um that uh with various signaling
Pathways basically there was a very
interesting part we call the notch
pathway that is responsible for uh
causing changes in the tumor
microenvironment which is able to cause
the occurrence of this disease and the
notch pathway along with some other
signaling Pathways you know that we
usually read in our cell biology classes
uh they will also affect the tumor
microenvironment which can interact with
the cells and determine the fate of the
cells if it grows into a network of
healthy cells or unhealthy cells
also we can note certain like I've given
the names of certain genes like it is
the pi uh Pi k3cd Gene it is involved in
the proliferation of the cell it is
involved in the development of the cell
and then T Cell receptor signaling like
it tells us that you know it's not just
limited to the B cell proliferation but
the other kinds of immune cells also
they all work in a niche which is where
the micro environment comes in then
certain genes that will affect the
metabolism of proteins and lipids which
can lead to the production of certain
signaling factors which may be faulting
always may be healthy and uh there are
also genes which can mutate it can um
contribute to the drug resistance or the
reoccurrence of the disease which is
also there and then since we know that
most of these mechanisms are molecular
and they involve the DNA sequences and
stuff so you will also look at
a CLL patients they will have higher
rates of translation and the regulation
by the ribosomes of the genes they will
be lowered so that also lead to the
occurrence of the disease as the
signaling when they occur in this uh the
DNA and RNA it will lead to the
occurrence of uh certain kinds of
infaulty cell cell cycle and the mitotic
spindles may be affected and these are
just like a bunch of
um you know phenomena that can occur
with the occurrence of this disease
what it can also help us do is it can
look it by we can look at biomarkers
that if we see that there are certain
genes or uh that are differentially
expressed and they can affect certain
functions of the um cells like the DNA
repairs will be altered the signaling
Pathways they will be altered it can
cause an inflammation or the it can
affect the organism of the cell like it
may cause some mitochondrial
dysfunction in the cells and it can also
uh cause some faulty occurrence of the
cellular processes and signaling Cycles
like we read about the calcium dependent
kinases and the BCR receptors Etc so
this was about it and when you do it in
silico it also gives you
a very thorough look at what uh like I
worked on the disease side of things so
I think it is a very thorough and a very
interactive way to look at things so I'm
very happy and I'm actually very happy
to be coming back here today to talk
about my projects and my journey as a
research fellow and it was very
interesting and I'm so thankful that I
was able to do this side of
bioinformatics things and I'm always
looking forward to learning more about
such stuff
well thank you for this and if there any
other any questions that you would like
to ask about writing a project or
anything in just in general please be
afraid to ask yes uh we do have a query
from uzma manzoor and she's asking have
you done all these courses online
yeah
so it's more so like the fellowship that
we did we mostly do it online and you
can see that they have a portal of the
courses so what you're supposed to do is
you're supposed to go over the study
material they will give you certain
videos also in the study material like
when I started with the transcriptomics
course I remember I was able to look at
how the Next Generation sequencing is
done how the
um the the I would say the samples are
prepared how do we map them to the genes
and what strategies are used so you
should be able to uh mostly you will be
doing these courses online and then you
can always get in touch with your
instructors if you have any doubts or if
you are stuck somewhere in doing the
assignments so that is how it works and
they've divided into lessons for each
topic so I think it makes it easier to
understand things and you can go at your
pace and you can start off with the
easier things and then work your way up
that is how we do it thank you so much
and I hope your query got answered